FreeMarkets big tech and free speech
often do not you know get along very
well because they have an interest to
their obviously to their investors and
then you have things happening on
patreon like the actual financial
backing is like MasterCard
kind of putting the pressure on to boot
people and now there's so many different
topics but I don't believe everyone has
a right to a platform let's shift a
little bit here because let's talk about
big tech because you've got an
interesting announcement idea comin but
just relative to the whole big tech
conversation and as someone that you now
you might be shadow band yeah you came
and we don't know if they're gonna get
us and shadow banning as I keep
endlessly repeating is now quite
literally in the Twitter Terms of
Service if you are an American it
doesn't apply to the Europeans for some
reason but if you're an American it is
now in the Terms of Service on Twitter
that they can throttle who sees your
tweets on top of that I just saw as of
the day we're taping this today that
they're gonna they're considering doing
a tip thing on Twitter yeah but think
how dangerous that means yeah that's an
interesting idea but now they're also
saying they can throttle you but then
that means they can also not just
control who whose information gets out
there but who can actually make money
too yeah it's a seriously dangerous
thing all that being said when it comes
to big tech as someone that's in this as
a creator and a youtuber and Twitter and
a boob person and all that stuff where
are you on regulation and what we should
do about this this thing that's
obviously pretty intimate so to you I
had to think a lot about this and I was
always that was one area it just
intersects with a lot of my interests as
big tech free speech oh my god this is
gonna be real interesting in the future
and we'll see how well that holds up
because free markets big tech and free
speech often do not you know get along
very well because they have an interest
to their obviously to their investors
and then you have things happening on
patreon like the actual financial
backing is like MasterCard kind of
putting the pressure on to boot
people and now there are so many
different topics but I don't believe
everyone has a right to a platform so I
just I I don't think that everyone has a
right to free speech in America in the
places where you are allowed to have
free speech that doesn't mean that
appointing the public square meaning the
public square now that doesn't mean that
a private company owes you a microphone
yeah so what about the people that say
but but Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
are he the avenues we communicate and if
there if you're not allowed on there
it's like saying to somebody 30 years
ago you can't get a telephone in your
house you know what's interesting to me
is that it's generally people on the
Left who are saying this or on the right
who are getting kind of throttled but on
the left it's like get them all off
Panama it's not the public square but I
think that when it hurts really
marginalized people of emotive words
they trickle down and so I don't know it
to not consider it the public square is
dangerous in some ways because then you
are really it's like but it's the it's
just so crazy it's just but it goes to
show how you're not gay because you
don't think the right way someone is can
isn't black if they don't think the
right way it's the ideology so if you
have the right ideology you'll be
allowed in the public square well that's
not the public square but it is weird
with Facebook in all these places
because as far as I'm concerned just
being that they're private companies
even if they were smart enough to create
a public square they still get to do
what they want to do yeah I mean I I
don't know what else to say about that
that's just that sucks the best line I
heard on this and this was in the middle
of me trying to figure out how I wanted
to fight this battle was everyone oh he
says but this time they have so much
power that it's different so the idea
would be that this time you libertarians
you kind of have to you have to put it
aside and let the government do it
because this is
because Google has so much information
so much this is the time and then you're
on Brook who I've had on who have you
chatted with your own you you should
definitely have him on from 9r and
Institute basically I mean it's the most
simple thing but he said it's so plainly
as if it was nothing that it really
destruct me he's like well if you
wouldn't have principles when they're
the hardest time to have those
principles that you don't really have
them right and so he's completely
against regulations so that leads me to
why over the last year and I just
announced it barely a month ago I
started locals come to allow creators to
own everything that they're doing own
all your content own all of your user
data set whatever rules you want in your
locals we started mine which we have
about 10,000 people in there now at
Rubin report.com and we got an iOS app
and a Google Play amazing but I'm not
pimping myself out here Bridgette
because this all leads to that you this
is the first time is being said publicly
you are the first creator on locals
people can go to feds e.com today pH ETS
a one we Phe t.a.s what I said no yes a
why dyslexia there put it on the screen
but you are the firt you are the first
creator beyond me that is on Locust calm
and we're super psyched to have you
there and we had literally about 5,000
people that reached out that within that
first couple weeks to create communities
and I was like Bridget's the right one
because you are just in the center of
all of this yeah I'm excited because
well there's a couple many reasons one
you put your money where your mouth is
you know a lot of that a lot of people
when I was I was too small to really I
was affected by people like Jordan and
you and Sam leaving patreon because you
took a lot of people who who subscribe
to me know I had my own friends angry at
me that were like if you left that it's
okay but but people cancel their patreon
accounts because of us so then a lot of
you guys got hurt it's fine
and again I don't I really don't like to
be the you know the victim II thing so
even I'm like alright shadow ban me
alright whatever I'll figure out a way
because I always have
you actually did figure out a way and
made something and a lot of people are
like we'll go make your own internet
like okay fine I will go make my own you
know plant it's a platform though is it
well it's it's a it's an on platform
Plataea it's a creator specific platform
different and one of the cool things
that we're going to be launching over
the next couple of months now that we're
adding some creators and you're just the
first of a whole bunch of mobile that
we're gonna add is that we're going to
be able to connect our communities so
they're able to connect your community
with like-minded people yeah so perhaps
if Dave and Bridget like each other will
connect our communities it'll it'll
strengthen our feeds and our fans will
be able to communicate with each other
and if one day you're like that Dave
Reubens real [ __ ] you'll just
disconnect the the connection and that's
it and the idea was let's give all of
the power back to the craters and make
sure that the day that the day that you
say something on dumpster fire that
YouTube's like we're done with this girl
yeah well guess what you don't have any
of I mean think I was how many
subscribers do you have on YouTube
ballpark
oh I mean I've only been on for like
three months so 11,000 about right great
the day that they find you too much of a
threat or whatever and hopefully by the
end send some subscribers your way but
but the point is that you have no way of
communicating with those eleven thousand
people they've chosen to smash your
channel but you can't get your message
out of them because the algorithm sits
between you and getting messages yeah
yeah this guess adequate I wish I had my
phone on me you get actual push
notifications on your phone so I think
we've built something pretty cool no
it's very happy that you're part of it
I'm so excited I'm excited I I was
telling David that I cried when I saw my
David yes yeah that I cried when I saw
just the that because it's just fantasy
so I started I made up the word fantasy
years ago because and it means
when reality becomes parody now in 2006
this didn't mean anything and now it's
like the culture has kind of caught up
to the word and then because social
media was so new I used that as my
social media name because they I didn't
really trust social media knew nothing
about it and I didn't and I wanted to
get the word out well I ate it Verdun
Lee became the brand before my company
did because my company went bankrupt
because I was 27 and didn't have a
business plan I was gonna make greeting
cards again trying to just be a voice
from people I felt like didn't have a
voice which was like divorced people and
people who had kids out of wedlock and
and that's where I started and then and
then it took on a whole other life of
its own which is a crazy journey and
probably the book I should write because
it's been and then I sigh you know just
fantasy back with the original logo and
I'm like we we I never gave up on this I
have it on my phone it's only it's the
test version but yeah and fantasy was
always meant to be
a content creation that's all I want I
wanted to be a production company and to
I like I said I mean I have scripted
podcasts I want to make I have
locals-only content that I want to put
on and and I see locals now or the
fantasy locals as my hub where I get to
do that and just keep expanding and
collecting people as long as I'm allowed
in the public forum
yeah but it's the home I mean what I'm
trying to tell me was its but it's your
digital home yeah you do whatever you
want your digital home you can't you
know our TOS our Terms of Service you
can't break the laws of the United
States across the board on locals but
beyond that one of the cool things is
you set the rules in your local yeah I
set the rules in my local so if
someone's just being purely evil in mind
I just don't want your money and goodbye
you're out you may have a different
policy related to what you know what
you're real pretty much yeah and mind
it's what I wrote in a kind of funny way
it's like it's not that I have three
strikes it's just like don't be a
relentless dick and if yeah if you just
can't do that then I don't want I don't
I don't want your money
yeah I mean that's how I feel it I call
it my gated community congratulations
well the new institutions are being
built what do you think though because
we're doing this as a subscription thing
about
that may be the day of the absolutely
free internet being the main driving
force of everything is kind of done
because that's sort of what I'm feeling
like yes I get it I'm not leaving
YouTube or Twitter or any of those
things for discovery for you though but
well they just stole your soul yes and
I'm like Twitter takes your soul and all
your information so one of the things I
love about yours is that I take that
stuff I'mI'm nuts I have no interest in
selling information people give me to
third parties none yep
I don't like it when other places do
that to me I have no interest in that if
I shut down and die it all dies with me
that's also very clearly written for my
partners like I don't want them taking
it and selling it and I just I I think
that the you know I was saying as I was
watching all of the past couple of years
the debates and the siloing of public
and private opinion is happening anyway
and I was saying everyone's gonna end up
going back to their domain names
everybody left their domain names to go
into these you know social media places
and now everyone's gonna start kind of
reverting back to those place they're
their homes their home pages do you
think that that's part of the problem
and a way to link them all and be social
so it's the few it's the future it's
amazing we I'm psyched amazing right
when I saw when you guys showed me the
demo I was like that I got in the car
with cousin Maggie really this is the
future
cuz it's social media meets you know
content creation
it's like patreon meets Twitter a little
bit yeah and it's Scrolls and it's sexy
it's just I'm so excited if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell